a coronavirus vaccine is seen as a key
weapon against the pandemic
but how much will shots cost in the u.s
some companies have said that a dose
could sell for as little as a few bucks
to as much as 25
and that vaccines may actually be
available fairly quickly by industry
standards
meaning less than two years as opposed
to more than 10.
it's called operation warp speed
that means bigger it means fast of more
than 160 groups racing to put a vaccine
on the market
a handful entered the final testing
stage within the first six months
that's much faster than the usual
process which can take years
and that's in part thanks to u.s
government money the administration
handed out more than 10 billion dollars
between march
and august there's an expectation
on the public's part that the drug
because it's been funded partially by
taxpayer money that the price will be
reasonable but investors have also
poured funds into drug makers and stocks
at some pharma companies have soared
that's putting pressure on big pharma to
make vaccines affordable while also
keeping investors happy
we wanted to know what does that mean
for the final price tag
developing a vaccine is a huge gamble
getting it from the lab to clinic can
cost billions of dollars
and not all of the companies that are
developing vaccines will end up with a
viable product
of all of the vaccines that start human
testing
about 66 of them will fail kenneth
cayton studies drug pricing at tough
center for the study of drug development
which receives grants from the
pharmaceutical industry he says vaccine
r
d is something few companies can afford
not a lot of companies actually
invest in this for a variety of reasons
one of them is
the poor likelihood of success and the
difficulty
of generating revenue on whatever
r d activities they have but in the case
of the coven 19 pandemic
government money is taking away a lot of
that risk by funding vaccine research
and development
and signing contracts to buy the
vaccines before they're even approved
two government deals with moderna and
pfizer would secure as many as 200
million doses by january next year
and that would mean both vaccines would
be free of charge to people in the us
at least initially to speed things up
pharma companies received additional
funds for manufacturing
and are already mass producing vaccines
while still conducting clinical trials
michael kinch is a biochemistry
professor and a vaccine historian
he says producing and storing vaccines
can be very expensive
under what conditions what temperatures
and humidity
and a number of things that again
oftentimes can take years to develop
it might be that we find out that
certain conditions ruin
of active vaccine there's also a
parallel scramble to secure billions of
medical grade vials and syringes that
are just as important as clinical trials
and the us isn't the only country trying
to secure doses for its citizens
assuming there are just seven billion
people which is probably an
underestimate
and that each one perhaps needs two
doses you're talking about a
monumental logistics challenge of being
able to
create double-digit billions
of different vaccine doses manufacturers
of glass vials have estimated that
worldwide demand because of the pandemic
will increase by 2 billion over the next
two years
since most of the medical supplies are
sourced overseas
the us government is giving american
glass makers and syringe suppliers
federal contracts to ramp up production
some americans are hesitant about taking
a coven 19 vaccine
because of concerns that development is
being rushed
to allay those concerns several industry
rivals are planning a joint pledge to
not seek regulatory approval
until the shots are proven to be safe
and effective
despite the hurdles some companies are
joining the crowded race because they
already have the technical capabilities
to do so
for instance novavac says it makes
business sense to repurpose the
technology it uses for a promising flu
vaccine
to develop one for coven 19.
plus financial backing from not just the
us government but also various countries
and nonprofits
have also given companies more of an
incentive to chip in than ever before
in return companies may get positive
coverage worldwide for stepping in
during a pandemic
or being one of those to find an
effective vaccine
lawmakers have said that drug makers
should be held accountable to taxpayer
dollars
some companies have said their vaccines
will be priced at cost because of the
current crisis
we will be providing vaccine at a
not-for-profit price during the
emergency
pandemic phase befiser and moderna have
said they still
intend to make a profit we will not sell
at a cost
kenneth caton from tufts points out that
some pharmaceutical companies with
portfolios of blockbuster drugs
should be able to absorb the cost of the
vaccine
sales from these products can help take
away some of the pressure to profit from
a single coronavirus vaccine
meanwhile the government is working with
commercial insurers as well as medicare
and medicaid so people won't have to pay
out of
there's also a government plan to help
fund the vaccines for the uninsured
black and latino communities have less
access to health care than white people
and they've been dying at
disproportionately higher rates during
the pandemic
while also making up a large part of
essential workers at greater risk for
exposure to the virus
so a free or affordable vaccine would be
one of the best ways to protect the most
vulnerable
and return to some level of normalcy
[Music]